foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video in this new
video I want to have a look at how so
the dragons exciting and Incredibly
shocking final episode after watching
the most recent episode of House of the
dragon and knowing where things are
heading in this season one finale I know
we're about to be in for one hell of an
amazing ride the dance of the Dragons
will officially begin in The Following
episode although I'm not ready for the
season to be over I'm more than ready to
see what will happen this Sunday
everyone fighting for Allison and aegon
as well as everyone fighting for
rhaenyra and Damon will need to heighten
their security and defense as if they
want to survive House of the Dragon
because the fire is finally about the
rain there is one thing all of you will
want to have on your side if you want to
make sure you're safe whenever heading
into battle online I want to discuss the
sponsor of this video Atlas VPN as I'm
sure most of you already know all of us
are at risk of having our identity
stolen on a daily basis as more and more
of our information and data goes on to
the internet what some of you might not
know is that one of the best way ways of
stopping this from happening is by the
use of a VPN service I actually use mine
every day in fact I won't turn on any of
my devices unless I'm already connected
well this month I've joined forces with
Atlas VPN to bring you the most
affordable deal on online protection for
as little as 1.99 each month they also
give you a 30 day money back guarantee
now other than guarding your online
identity Atlas VPN also blocks malware
and malicious links they will make sure
your Google searches are private and
they'll give you access to online
shopping deals and even notify you
whenever someone is trying to steal your
identity one of my favorite things about
Atlas VPN is it also gives you access to
other regions content on the different
streaming services like Netflix for
example if something is only available
in the UK all you have to do is switch
your IP address to gain access to it in
the US right now Atlas VPN is running a
massive discount to where you can
actually get a three-year subscription
for only 1.99 each month and don't
forget that also has is a 30-day
money-back guarantee all of you can jump
on that deal right now before time Runs
Out by going to the link in my
description I recommend grabbing that
deal now once again I would like to
thank atlasvpn for sponsoring the video
now let's see what will happen in the
final episode of House of the Dragons
first season one of the very first
things we see in HBO's official new
video is rainey's in her Dragon melees
Racing to Dragonstone to inform renera
of her father's death as well as aegon's
coronation now renera will know the
greens have their sights set on her and
her sons however they don't want all of
them dead at least not right away in
another scene from the final episode we
do see Damon and Serato reuniting on
dragonstone's bridge not only does
Serato have members of the kingsguard
behind him but so does Damon as well
some of them are fighting for aegon in
his side while the others are there for
rhaenyra and Damon now if you look at
Serato in this photo notice how there is
someone standing right in the middle of
him and Damon that looks like ranera
holding a letter while she is wearing a
a crown on her head that should be her
fathers who was hand delivered by the
cargo brother who was helping rhaenys
escape from King's Landing it does seem
Serato has brought an offer to settle
things without any actual Bloodshed but
that letter must say something insulting
and that's why Damon is holding out his
sword as you all know this does make the
second time we've seen Damon shove his
Valyrian steel in serato's face in this
same exact location it will be very
interesting to see how and why Damon
will allow him to live after this we
already know how much they hate each
other and although Damon does look to be
outnumbered here we all know there are
several dragons right behind them on
Dragonstone they could easily have
Serato answer Kristen Cole burned alive
right now if they really wanted
obviously rhaenyra and Damon will not
accept their offer anything less than
ranera getting the Iron Throne is seen
as unacceptable she wants what is
rightfully hers and they will fight to
get it in this final episode we will see
rhaenyra form a small counsel of her own
known as the black Council the major
members who will make up Rainier's black
Council or Damon rhaenys Laura Corliss
valerion and her sons Jason locarys as
well as several members of The King's
Guard now if you noticed in the most
recent episode we heard the greens
discuss how Lord Baratheon of Storm's
end still hasn't swore fealty to either
side this is something we will see get
brought up again in the last episode
when rainy says Lord Baratheon should
favor them since she has of that blood
on her mother's side obviously everyone
will be fighting to get all of the
remaining major houses on their side
because they will need every man they
can get to win and hold on to the Iron
Throne we did see something like this in
Game of Thrones when Jon and Sansa tried
to win over many houses in the north
before fighting Ramsay well it will be
no different here in House of the Dragon
there are still several houses and
Storm's end the vale white Harbor and
Winterfell who need a swear fealty to
either runera or aegon in this season
finale we will see Rainier's sons
jacaris and lucari's offer to go through
these houses so they can get them to
join their mother that's what you see
happening in this scene right here now
rhaenyra will allow her sons to go so
long as they go as envoys only she does
not want them fighting under any
circumstances now since she carries is
the older son ranera will have him go on
the longer and more dangerous Mission he
will go to the vale white Harbor in
Winterfell while lucarius goes on the
much shorter flight to Storm's end we
will see them leave right before this
episode is over in the shot of
Dragonstone right here we see three
dragons leaving the island I believe
that is jakari's on his Dragon for Max
Lou carries on his Dragon a racks and
that might also be Damon on his Dragon
caraxis eventually Damon will leave for
harrenhal so they might have him leave
when rainer's Sons fly off on their solo
missions now before Damon does leave
Dragonstone we will see him introduce us
to a new dragon in the show here we see
the old Dragon Verma Thor who was once
written by King jihari's Targaryen who
we did meet in the first episode of this
season Verma Thor is already very old
and it hasn't had a rider since Harry's
died several decades ago either Damon is
looking for more dragon eggs because
they will need them or he's looking in
after the dragons because he also knows
they will need new Riders to take them
into battle there are a handful of
different dragons living on Dragonstone
who will need a new Rider now although
renera has more dragons than her enemies
most of them are either riderless or
very small like the dragons her son's
ride unfortunately most of them would be
no match for aemon and his incredibly
massive she Dragon vegar who we will
also see in this final episode in fact
this will be one of the greatest scenes
from the entire series once again
unfortunately for rhaenyra's son who
carries valerion he will meet his
greatest enemy when he arrives at
Storm's end when lucarius arrives at the
home of house Baratheon he will
immediately notice someone is already
there amond and his Dragon Veigar arrive
several days earlier and they've already
won over lord Baratheon as lucarius
valerion enters the round Hall aemon
will be there standing beside Lord
Baratheon as he hand and delivers his
mother's message during this scene aemon
will confront lucari's valerion about
his eye as you all know it was lucarius
who slashed at eamon's face and removed
his eye well as you can imagine aemon
wants to settle the score he wants an
eye for an eye and it looks like this
scene has been adapted exactly the way
it was written in George R Martin's
novel Fire and Blood here we do see
aemon removing the cover from his eye
and I really hope he will reveal
something he has underneath of it now
although Lord Baratheon and Amon have
already made a deal he still doesn't
want him fighting littler carries in his
Hall Lord Baratheon will send lucari's
away with a message of his own basically
letting renera know he's not going to be
her servant to sin against her foes when
lucarius leaves the hall and runs back
outside you can see there is a massive
rain storm happening right outside of
Storm's end which is very fitting I
might add now this is something I
absolutely love because this setting
will make for a very ominous dark and
unsettling scene not only is it
happening at 9 8 but it's also raining
with the lightning and thunder lashing
out in the back unfortunately for Lou
carries valerion there is a scary
monster hiding behind the castle walls
and there's another monster right behind
him who's looking for vengeance in
another one of these shots we see
lucari's and his little baby dragon
barely flying in the storm it looks like
the wind is about to blow him right off
the dragon and then we get our money
shot as vegar's insanely Largemouth
opens wide as she snaps at something in
the sky now if you don't already know
I'm sure most of you can use your
imagination and think of how this will
end I won't go into everything that
happens in this scene because I just
recently made a video about it where I
read exactly what George R Martin had
written in Fire and Blood as I've said
before this will be one of the greatest
sequences in this season as well as the
whole show this will make for an
incredibly amazing ending to the first
season and I know there will be millions
and millions of fans demanding for more
now for those of you who don't know I
will be making video goes during the
entire off-season although this season
will be ending on this Sunday my videos
will not stop releasing like I did with
every season of Game of Thrones and this
first season of House of the Dragon I
will make videos about everything that
happens during the off season as they're
filming the next one and I will also
make videos about what I think will
happen in the second season hopefully
all of you will stick around for those
ones as well now let me know what all of
you think about this final episode Down
Below what do you think will happen and
is there anything I'm overlooking leave
me some of your thoughts as always I
want to thank all of you for watching
this video I hope all of you have a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign